Speaker 1: Generally speaking, people who have
done nothing wrong, don't ask for immunity in
order to testify or to talk to investigators. Our
old friend Alex Jones is asking for immunity if
he is to discuss his role and knowledge related
to the Jan. six Trump riots. It is not a good
week for Alex Jones bankruptcy, but a bankruptcy
that may be calculated to try to shield assets
from people he's ultimately going to have to pay
money to. Which lawyers say isn't even going to
work. And now Alex Jones wants immunity. New York
Times Report Alex Jones Reaches Out to Justice
Department About Trump riot interview. The effort
by the Trump ally to get an immunity deal is the
latest sign of progress in the investigation,
which recently brought on a well-regarded
prosecutor. The federal investigation into
efforts to overturn the election seems to gain
traction. Justice Department has brought in a new
prosecutor, Alex Jones, the host of the conspiracy
driven media outlet Infowars and a key player
in the pro-Trump trap to Stop the Steal movement
is in discussions about an agreement to detail
his role in the rally. Through his lawyer, Jones
said he has given the government a formal letter
conveying his desire to speak to prosecutors.
The lawyer, Norm Norm Parris, maintained Jones had
not engaged in any criminal wrongdoing that day.
As a condition of being interviewed, Jones
has requested immunity from prosecution. Now
the reason they're giving is he distrusts the
government, so we are to believe Alex Jones
believes and knows that he did nothing wrong, but
he is so distrustful of the government. He thinks
if he talks to them, they will find some crime
to pin on him anyway. And that's why he wants
immunity. While convincing federal prosecutors to
grant him immunity could be an uphill climb for
Alex Jones. His discussions with the Justice
Department suggest that the investigation
could be gathering momentum. Two weeks ago,
another prominent Stop the Steal organizer,
Ali Alexander, an associate of Jones, revealed he
got a subpoena from a grand jury that is seeking
information on a broad swath of people, rally
planners, members of Congress, others close to
Trump about what happened on that day. This is
absolutely fascinating. Now again, in general,
innocent people don't try to get immunity as a
condition of speaking to investigators. Alex Jones
wants us to believe it's not because he believes
he did something wrong. It's because he believes
they are going to sandbag him because he doesn't
trust the government. Now, as in, I spoke to some
investigators about this and they said, Listen,
anyone can always say they're going to try to
find something to pin on me. But that in general,
they genuinely, if they don't think Alex Jones is
the top dog, right, you want to use people to get
the top dogs. That's the general idea here that
why would you talk to Alex Jones first and even
consider immunity if you thought he was at the
top? No, that's the guy you want to take down. So
they believe there's people higher up than Jones.
If that's the case. You want to genuinely have a
goodwill working relationship with the witness,
because that's how they're going to tell you.
Ideally everything or everything you want to know.
So only the most paranoid person would think, even
in a cooperation agreement, they're going to try
to sandbag me. It just doesn't really make sense.
It's not typically how these investigations work.
Is it possible that they want to charge Alex
Jones? Sure, it's possible. But if they're looking
to him as a cooperating witness to get bigger
names, they're they're not going to deceptively
sandbag him. They might be upfront and say, we're
not ready to give you immunity because we actually
do think you might have committed crimes, but
let's talk. That's the way things can go that way,
for sure. But the idea that out of nowhere,
they're going to sandbag him with the most
serious charges. It's just not to the advantage of
investigators if they want to get what they think
is the most valuable stuff from Alex Jones.
Now the other side of this is that this all
could be a stall tactic. We've also talked about
and we talked about yesterday that in general,
there's lots of people on the periphery of the
Justice Department investigation and the January
6th investigation into what is going on, what
happened and who was involved. The January 6th.
And with a midterm election coming up and with
an attorney general and Merrick Garland, who
is of questionable conviction when it
comes to really prosecuting wrongdoing
of higher ups when it comes to the January
six circumstances running out the clock and
stalling as much as possible isn't a crazy idea.
So it is not an illogical strategy for Alex Jones
to ask for immunity, even if he knows he's
not going to get it simply as a delaying
tactic to say, I am willing, I am willing,
but we've got to figure out immunity first.
Also remember that if he has relevant information,
immunity might do more good than compelling him to
testify, because then he'll do what he already
did, which is just plead the Fifth Amendment,
which he's constitutionally able to do. There's
no there's no question about that thinking. From
a practical investigative perspective, you might
end up getting more from giving him immunity than
from just compelling him to testify because we
know what him and Eric Trump did. They plead the
fifth hundreds of times. So another not great week
for Alex Jones. We will see if he gets immunity.